when i signed the american rescue plan
last week i said help is on the way
this week on every i can report isn't
just on the way it's here
sooner than many ever thought possible
over the next 10 days
we'll reach two goals two giant goals
the first is 100 million shots in
people's arms
will have been completed within the next
10 days and 100 million
checks in people's pockets in the next
hundred days
shots and arms and money in pockets
that's important the american rescue
plan is already doing
what it was designed to do make a
difference
in people's everyday lives we're just
getting started
by the time all the money is distributed
eighty-five percent of american
households will have gotten a one
thousand
four hundred dollar rescue checks to
give
more to give one more example for the
average family of two parents and two
children
making a combined income of 110 000 a
year
that's gonna add five thousand six
hundred dollars
for them five thousand six hundred
dollars okay
and the plan does a lot more it extends
unemployment insurance for the 11
million americans unemployed than any
who will be unemployed
in the near term it will help hundreds
of thousands of small businesses keep
their doors open
which makes a gigantic difference in
neighborhoods and communities
if you have a drugstore if you have a a
beauty shop a hardware store
it's the center of small communities and
it gets our schools and resources they
need to open
safely it provides the biggest
investment in child care
since world war ii and it provides food
and nutrition help
for the millions of families keep them
from going hungry keeping a roof over
their heads
and it expands health care coverage and
lowers healthcare costs for so
many people and it will cut child
poverty in half
in this country that's the estimate
child poverty will be cut in half
as a consequence of what's in this
recovery act and it will generate
economic growth for the entire nation
that's why major economists left right
and center support this plan
even wall street has agreed according to
moody's
by the end of this year this law will
spur our economy to create
seven million new jobs
and does one more thing it focuses on
rebuilding the backbone of this country
working families the middle class
people who built this country but as i
said last week
it's one thing to pass a historic piece
of legislation like the american rescue
plan
and it's quite another to implement it
and the devil
is in the details it requires fastidious
oversight
to make sure the relief arrives quickly
equitably and efficiently with no waste
or fraud
in your bank account in your mailbox to
the local business
in your community and to your child's
school
look i've been here before when
president obama and i came to office in
2009
he put me in charge of implementing the
recovery act
which helped us recover and rebuild
during the great recession
i was authorized to put together a team
including an accountability board with
inspectors general
from different agencies that were
affected by the act
to make sure we got the roughly 800
billion dollars
out out of the countryside by the book
and quickly over 18 months i talked to
literally
almost 100 over 150 mayors
all governors except one constantly
going over the granular detail
of the implementation of this
legislation that legislation
and the effort put us on a path from
crisis
to recovery to resurgence accordingly
to the oversight board that is of
inspectors general
they said we got it done with less than
two tenths
of one percent waste or fraud
that's not what the previous
administration did though
when the congress i sure passed the
cares act
it cares that the congress created a
committee
of inspectors general to make sure every
penny of that money was spent as it was
directed
but one of the first things the previous
administration did
was fire the head of the inspector
general's committee
so when congress passed what was
intended to be a small business relief
program
it instead became a free-for-all for
well-connected companies
and mainstream mainstream businesses
from hardware stores to beauty salons
that needed to help most were left
behind
400 000 are now gone we will not
let that happen this time i learned from
my experience
implementing the recovery act just how
important it is to have someone
who can manage all the moving parts with
efficiency
speed and integrity and accountability
that's the sort of management we've seen
in our fight against the virus
with jeff science our covert response
coordinator
and today i'm pleased to announce
and introduce another gifted manager to
coordinate our implementation
of the american rescue plan gene
sperling
gene will be on the phone with mayors
and governors red states blue states
the source of constant communication a
source of
guidance and support and above all a
source of accountability
for all of us to get the job done she's
been here before
the only person in history to serve as
director of economic of the national
economic council
twice he led successful efforts
to deliver relief to small businesses
and unemployed americans
in the obama biden administration and in
the clinton administration
i spoke with gene earlier today
alongside my economic team
he's ready to get to work in fact he's
already hit the ground running
and together we're going to make sure
that the benefits of the american rescue
plan
go out quickly and directly to the
american people
where they belong let me close with this
help is here and hope is here
in real and tangible ways we're just
days away from 100 million shots
and millions in the arms of millions of
americans that's the way
that's the way on the way to get every
single american
access to the vaccine 100 million checks
going into the pockets and or direct
deposits going into the pockets of
americans
on the way to a million more millions of
more americans
that's real progress we have a lot more
to do
we have to prove to the american people
that their government can deliver for
them
and do it without waste or fraud
that we can vaccinate the nation that we
can get our kids safely back in school
that we can get our economy back on
track by helping hundreds of thousands
of small businesses open and stay open
and that we can give people this nation
a fighting chance again
with relief checks lower child care
costs
lower health care costs and so much more
that's our job that's our responsibility
and the process will be growing the
economy as well
we're gonna have to stay on top of every
dollar spent through the american rescue
plan
and that's what we're gonna do we can do
this
we will do this god bless you all
help us on the way and may god protect
our troops thank you very very much
should president trump help uh promote
the vaccine among skeptics sir
especially those republicans who say
that
they're not willing to take a lot of
reports from
serious reporters like you saying that
i discussed it with my team and they say
the thing that has
more impact than anything trump would
say to the
magga folks is what the local doctor
what the local preachers what the local
people in the community say
so i urge i urge all local docs and
and ministers and priests and to talk
about
why why it's important to get it
to get that vaccine and even after that
until everyone
is in fact vaccinated to wear this mask
thank you